ja Sandy wir bauen die Dichte Fichte
beenden dann Minecraft loser heute ihr
bekommt natürlich auch ein Downloadlink
den sieht der Welt können wir euch
gleich schon sagen an alle hier als
kleiner dafür dass er jetzt schon hier
im Livestream mit dabei seid Leute es
ist ein krasser prank geplant es ist ein
geiler prank geplant
ich glaube mein Ziel ist es jetzt diesen
Turm abzubauen weil ich will nicht dass
die Leute wenn sie die Map kriegen
diesen ekelhaften Turm haben und wir
bauen natürlich die was nein der Turm
bleibt
ey wie hoch hat die sich denn gebaut der
ist ja total dumm ich musste gleich eine
Holzschaufel machen um mir runter zu
kommen
ach du scheiße Digger Sandra wie hoch
hast du dich denn gebaut
warum jetzt muss ich das hier abbauen
scheiße aus
du machst das nicht normal wir machen
hier die Welt gerade schön für unsere
Leute und ich ich bin mir wieder 10
Minuten nur damit beschäftige deine
Scheiße abzubauen
du kannst mich daran
weil ich dich eine Stunde
Nummer 1 meine Damen und Herren ich
zeige euch das jetzt mal ich drücke
drauf heute zack hat das Spiel verlassen
jetzt schauen wir uns anders
korrekt für den perma-band oh nein ist
das schon durch ach lol warum
[Musik]
weil du es vorhattest gemacht ja aber
einfach um das schon mal vorweg zu
nehmen das ist jetzt gar nicht passiert
warte ich kann aber dich wieder ändern
einfach
[Gelächter]
ich habe den drecks Turm abgebaut Leute
schaut euch das an na gut wenigstens
müssen wir uns jetzt einfach nur runter
bauen
[Musik]
du kleiner der Plan ist dass
wir jetzt die Dichte Fichte bauen und
sah Langzeitprojekt wir wollten eine Bar
bauen unbedingt für seine mich in
Minecraft so das Handy wo wollen wir die
Dichte Fichte hinbauen können das
gestern aus wir hatten in die Gäste auf
der Insel eigentlich war mal so der Plan
das paar andere Minecraft auch mal
vorbeikommen andere Youtuber noch nie
gefragt
Laser darf ich jetzt einmal was machen
was denn ich will dich einmal töten
das doch nie weil du es nicht hinkriegst
doch einfach du darfst dich aber nicht
wehren bitte einmal
[Musik]
Vorankommen
beruhigt dich der Fichte das ist mein
größter Traum ja mach mal am Ende oh
mein Gott ich darf umbringen Moment in
ganz Minecraft loser also die schönsten
Momente waren die wo ich auf dem Server
war woanders noch nicht drauf war
hier können wir auch hinbauen ne hier
dann hat man einen schönen Blick ja dann
wollen wir die hier hin du kannst mal
hier so Bäume hinbauen nur wenige
Minuten später
was machst du ich baue Bäume
setzen einfach hin man baut doch keinen
Baum
könnte man eine Mod spielen
[Musik]
wird auch jeden Tag
ich bin nicht aggressiv
aber seiner Schauspieler
[Musik]
hi du hast jetzt einmal gelernt wie man
baumpflanzt und pflanzt direkt einen
halben Schwarzwälder kirschwald hier hin
ja ich sehe nur noch Bäume
[Musik]
kommen
ich mir das vorgestellt hätte
das zwei drei Monaten wieder hier auf
den Server gekommen wären und einfach
mal geschaut hätten die Leute die Dichte
Fichte bauen da hast du irgendwas
verstanden denkst die Leute können jetzt
hier auf den Server gehen danach oder
was
ja
Sandy ja ich stelle jetzt den braustein
hin dann haben wir die Dichte Fichte
fertig meiner Ansicht nach oh ich komme
ja Leute das ist die Dichte Fichte wir
hätten hier vorne natürlich jetzt noch
irgendwie Hocker hinstellen können aber
ehrlich gesagt fehlt dafür so ein
bisschen die Zeit das könnt ihr aber
natürlich machen denn ihr bekommt die
Map zum Download ja Freunde das ist auf
jeden Fall loser gewesen sein wollen wir
noch mal kurz eine Runde drehen über
unsere Insel okay ganz schnell gebaut in
den kleinen Wald die Bäume die Sonne
heute gebaut hat dass sie was anderes
Haus das heißt ja eigentlich immer
gedacht
ich habe eine Villa dass sie wenig zu
tun ne halt's Maul ja dann haben wir ja
hier die ganzen Wege die wir gebaut
haben hier schön mit den Blöcken mit den
Steinen alle fünf Blöcke perfekt gepasst
hier vorne dass das genau runter geht
ins Portal hier unten auf der anderen
Seite nur auf einen Moment
dann seid Ihr hier unten
hin so Mittelpunkt ich mache hier gerade
eine schöne Verabschiedung hier vorne
noch weitergehen der Weg dahinten zum
Wasser hin ich habe mir so tolle Sachen
ausgemalt
alt hier vorne der Fluss der Wasserfall
den man hier gebaut haben ja das war wir
hatten schon richtig hübsche Insel ey
Leute ein bisschen
was stolz bin
alle Blumen gesammelt
hier ist mein Baumhaus Bello
wir haben verhandlungsmenschen hier
angespuckt zwei drei Mal und diese
ganzen Tierart fallen gelassen
[Musik]
oh mein Gott sollten wir eigentlich noch
erweitern der Weg sollte eigentlich hier
weitergehen hier vorne runter eigentlich
der Fluss hier vorne mitten durch hier
noch ein kleiner Wasserfall hier
zwischen unseren versteckten Items
hier ich weiß aber da muss ich getraut
damals die Glocke anzurühren aber dann
haben wir sie doch mitgenommen für den
Pferdestall ich habe das Pferdestall
leider kaputt gemacht
[Musik]
schön beenden es hat mir sehr viel Spaß
gemacht
[Musik]
warte
Bekleidung aus ja ich sicher meine
Sachen Sandra du sicher dass jetzt auch
alle deine Sachen
eine Luca Kiste komm mal her hier diese
Kiste die ja gerade offen ist da packst
du jetzt alle deine Sachen rein ich habe
gar nichts mehr ich bin noch gestorben
rein damit wir beide alle Sachen die wir
haben für die Leute in die Kisten packen
weißt du und jetzt darfst du mich töten
seiner Moment ist gekommen oh mein Gott
Leute das
[Musik]
waren total geiles Gefühl das war
Minecraft loser jetzt mal ganz kurz
schlafen mach hier das neue Tag anfängt
dann zeige ich euch jetzt den Stream den
seed einmal hier in der Folge geht ihr
natürlich dann auch in der
Zusammenfassung das hier ist der sieht
oh mein Gott das ist ein kurzer sieht
jetzt sieht es eingeblendet 110 2038 2
und äh dann geht's in in anderthalb
Wochen geht's weiter mit dem neuen
Minecraft weg von uns das war's denn
hier hast du noch abschließende Worte
TTT es war total toll Minecraft
offiziell vorbei in zwei Wochen geht's
weiter mit unserem neuen Minecraft bei
könnt ihr euch drauf freuen
[Musik]